Khalil and East didn't know life outside
the refugee camp under Israeli
occupation
this morning the 20 year old was buried
in the camp Cemetery after being killed
by Israeli forces
he was named after his uncle who was
killed when Israeli soldiers invaded the
old city of nablis in 2002.
family and friends say Khalil believed
in armed resistance
he inherited his uncle's name and
approached to fighting the occupation he
was courageous he saved money and bought
a locally made weapons fight for his
homeland
asked to be buried next to his friend
Muhammad another fighter killed by
Israeli forces in April
what do you expect from Israel they
don't fear God we don't have anyone to
help us all we can do is pray Khalil was
shot in the head during confrontations
between Palestinian Fighters and Israeli
soldiers
Israeli forces have raided nablas in
large numbers to demolish the house of
Osama tawil a Palestinian that Israel
accusers of participating amongst other
Palestinians in an attack that left one
Israeli soldier killed
a military Court charged Usama and
another Palestinian with killing a
soldier who was guarding Israeli
settlers at a March in October
osama's mother Huda says the family
moved out of the house a few weeks ago
after receiving the demolition order
the Israeli military has a policy of
destroying the homes of Palestinians
believed to be responsible for killing
Israelis as a part of that policy at
least 11 homes have been demolished in
the occupied West Bank so far this year
their so-called policy of deterrence is
not working because every new generation
follows their predecessors in resisting
the occupation they can demolish the
concrete but not our will
the Palestinian Health Ministry says
Israeli forces have killed more than 160
Palestinians since January at least 38
of them Annapolis
while Fighters here have promised
Revenge
for mothers nothing will ever make up
for the Heartbreak and the loss
the occupied West Bank